con nosotros a alejandro pérez
periodista de espn y especialista en
baloncesto alejandro le damos las
gracias por acompañarnos hola
alejandro que podemos esperarnos de esta
segunda semana de la final a la luz de
lo que vimos en la primera semana
lo primero me parece que los dos equipos
tienen en claro que este quinto partido
es
prácticamente decisivo porque
estadísticamente está comprobado que el
que gana el quinto en una serie empatada
2 a 2 tiene un amplio margen de
posibilidades de quedarse con la serie
con el título uno imagina que cada uno
de los equipos buscará hacer lo que le
dio buenos resultados en los dos
partidos que ganó hasta ahora me imagino
a un golden state tratando de hacer
pesar su condición de local de ser el
dueño de casa y tratando de hacer una
buena defensa en los dos partidos que
ganó lo hizo a partir de una excelente
tarea defensiva porque después adelante
en el ataque tiene muchas variantes
tiene muchos hombres con gol más allá de
que el hombre determinante con casi 34
puntos de promedio por partido es este
plan claro pero tiene armas las
posibilidades de golden state nacen a
partir de su defensa en boston todo lo
contrario es un equipo que defiende muy
pero muy bien lo ha demostrado aún en
los partidos que ha perdido
y sin embargo me parece que tiene que
recuperar lo que le permitió ganar los
dos partidos que es el juego de pases
cuando en la ofensiva
comparten el balón lo hacen circular los
llevan de un lado a otro siempre
encuentran buenos tiros y sobre todo
hombres que acompañen a las dos figuras
del equipo abraham y a texto necesitan
que horford que smart e igual que otros
hombres también anoten y eso lo va a
conseguir pasándose el balón da la
impresión de que los celtics dependen
mucho más del funcionamiento colectivo
de que todos los hombres cumplan sus
roles y de que golden state a diferencia
de ellos pueda resolver con una gran
noche de stephen corry puede ser esa una
clave importante de cara a lo que resta
de la final
exactamente en los acompañantes de kerry
como yo decía él ha sido la figura
emergente del equipo muy por encima del
resto y sus acompañantes han sido muy
regulares ninguno ha tenido una
actuación de sólida consistente a lo
largo de toda la serie tuvieron
altibajos en cada uno de los partidos
ese grupo de secundarios necesitan dar
un paso adelante con más regularidad en
el caso de boston es cierto que juega
más en equipo que tiene más
un estilo más de conjunto pero va a
necesitar ser efectivo no para dar
balones que es clave y dominar en la
tarea rebotera
este formato que nos espera a partir de
este lunes cuando se va a jugar un
partido en cada sede en lugar de dos
de inclina la balanza a favor de alguno
de los dos hay algunos de los equipos
que puede haberse beneficiado por
probablemente por los reposos o por este
cambio de ritmo
seguramente es así porque ahora pasa a
ser una final de solamente tres partidos
estos cuatro no corren más no sirvieron
para que ninguno sacara ventaja entonces
queda una serie de tres partidos y
matemáticamente golden state teniendo
dos de esos partidos como local tiene
indudablemente ventaja pero no se puede
descuidar ya nos pagó con una derrota en
el primer partido la localía entre dos
equipos tan parejos y de tan alto nivel
realmente está demostrando que no es
decisiva pero me imagino a un golden
estoy queriendo aprovecharse de de ser
el dueño de casa y va a salir a jugar
muy agresivo sobre todo en defensa
alejandro le agradecemos mucho haber
estado con nosotros tratando de